for hearings all day we're not planning
on executing anything next week but we
will have hearings all day the following
week we're going to exact the bills that
we're hearing next week the following
week um then
reports our committee clerk tells us
that if we had a report today it has to
be submitted by noon time or 1:00 I said
well we'll get out of here before that I
think but I know it's tough for a lot of
new people to be writing reports because
they got to figure out how do they do
that and then it's got to go be reviewed
so what I would like to ask everyone is
uh and I mentioned this before the
Democrat reports send them to the leader
here Alison nap she'll review them and
then send them to me so all the Democrat
reports send them to your leader she'll
review them and send them to me um for
grammar or whatever uh the Republic
reports come to me then I'll assemble
them then I send them to our committee
clerk then the committee clerk sends it
to the the speaker's office and the
clerk's office um I would like to I'd
like to have them as soon as possible
because yesterday we were told there's
not many bills on for next week but
there some more coming on today and
yesterday if I can have them at least by
Friday night that way way in between me
running a deliberative session on
Saturday and going to a fire truck push
thing on Sunday I can review all these
reports so that I'm able to submit them
timely next week so that they get on the
following calendar so if you can get
them done in a couple hours great but
I'm thinking not and I don't want to
have a gun to your head I want to I want
nice reports and I want you the new guys
to have time to figure out and ask
questions you know and I'm available I
know representative nap's available if
you have questions about writing reports
so try to get them in at least by Friday
night do your best as soon as possible
because they'd like us to finish the
report so we can move them on we have 10
bills we're voting on today so the rule
that I got was don't wait until you get
all the 10 reports which might be 20
reports but as soon as you get enough
reports send them up but I am
anticipating we have a good committee
I'm going to get everybody's report by
Friday night we they're going to have 10
on the agenda some might be consent some
might not be consent whatever but I'd
like to get these 10 out of here as of
yesterday we still had like 21 bills
total so these are 10 today probably
going to do seven next week and I left
maybe five so that we can EXA those
seven the following week have time for
some hearings and I'm sure we're going
to get more bills so then I could fill
in the hours with the more bills um I
had the committee clerk send out to
everybody the timing sheet when we have
to get these early bills out of here
some are March 3rd some are March 20th
I'm on a schedule that I hope we can all
live with that if we keep doing the way
we've been doing we'll be done before
the end of February and if that's true
we won't need to have any hearings on
vacation week
and um which would be nice that we
finish all the early bills right now
it's 21 but I haven't check today to see
if we picked up
anymore so that's just some housekeeping
things you I passed around my card
because it has my cell phone and my
regular email and some of you have been
sending me stuff to that it's easier for
me to respond to you guys if you send it
to my personal email and call me on my
cell at any time and I guess it takes a
message if I don't pick it up so I can
get back to you anybody have any
questions no can we all
rise going to ask representative donelly
to lead us in the pledge
today Al to the FL of the United States
of America and to the Republic for which
it stands one nation under God
indivisible with liy and jce for all
thank you I call today's exec session on
these 10 bills to order the first bill
that we be executing is
hb13 relative to ohrv operation on
certain highways within the town of
Windsor uh I believe attorney Bridal you
have a motion to make uh yeah yes thank
you Mr chair I make a motion to retain
this bill uh representative Donnelly
second so we have a motion and a second
any discussion the maker would you like
to speak to your motion uh yes thanks
again um the prime sponsor reached out
to us uh asked us to retain this bill I
believe they think it's something they
can do at the local level so they asked
us to retain it for now thank you the
second wish to speak uh no thank you
that covers it is there any other
discussion by the members of the
committee seeing none I'll ask the clerk
to read the
role we're voting on
voting on HB 113 to retain
it representative Davis yes
representative G yes representative
Donnelly yes the clerk votes yes
representative Bridal yes representative
Dupont yes representative Looney yes
representative Taylor yes representative
NAB yes representative Veil yes
representative Baldwin yes represent
representative Derby yes representative
Ryan Yes representative elberger yes
representative Sergeant
yes in favor
16 and the chair will vote Yes oh sorry
and the chair sorry and the chair sorry
and the chair this happened to my prior
chair they always forget to call the
chair
that's so I think that's unanimous yes
okay thank you so HB 113 voted to retain
moving on hb1 127 FN 127 FN extending
the closing date of the ohrv trails on
the Connecticut River headquarters
property from September 30th to Columbus
Day representative Davis you have a
motion yes thank thank you Mr chair I
make a motion ought to pass thank you
and representative Gould so we have a
motion in a second representative Davis
would you like to speak to your motion
yes thank you I see this more of a of an
economic development Bill more than an
ohrv Bill uh the people in Pittsburgh
are desperate for these last two weeks
of business the opposition that I saw uh
through emails and people that testified
here uh the the private opposition were
there was nobody from the Pittsburgh
area it was all people from down state
it was
uh the closest would would have been
Berlin which is about 65 70 Mi away none
of them which are affected by this bill
the OHV trails that we're talking about
they're nowhere's near the road they're
all off-road there's no noise complaints
no dust complaints the only possible
other push back would be hunting and all
the trails around this 10 m approximate
10 mile area are are open for that extra
two weeks we're not looking for anything
longer than
that uh so so I don't see how that
should differentiate that 10 miles from
the rest of the trails where hunting
comes into play usually it doesn't get
real busy until after the leaves drop
which I believe is after Columbus Day so
I think that's another moot
point
uh trying to think of the other uh yeah
so there's no no local complaining the
only thing is they're trying to get a
little more business we don't get the
snow we used to so Winters are a little
more harsh up there and this would kind
of offset
that thank you representative ghoul do
you wish to speak to you a second anyone
else wish to speak on this bill
representative
Darby thank you Mr and representative
Ryan um I have a couple of comments
briefly to make um first of course I
understand that this is important to the
town of Pittsburgh and I respect uh the
need to uh you know to generate Revenue
up in um up in Pittsburgh however I'm
concerned that this is um uh usurping um
local control uh there is a um there's
the um the local Citizens Council which
is responsible for making sure that
conservation easement is enforced um
they just uh worked with the uh dncr um
last May to um to create a Five-Year
Plan prior to that um during that
assessment there was no request for
extending the um season um they dncr
also said that they'd be happy to uh
evaluate this um if they were to receive
a request by April 1st so it's l it's
likely that no uh legislation is
required at all for this even uh
councelor Kennedy when he came when he
um uh questioned the um the the vote
against extending the season in 2024
asked for only a one-year extension as
opposed to a permanent
extension this this is uh there's a
conservation easement that um is uh that
basically um coordinates the the land
owner's rights with the state's rights
and make sure that uh local citizens are
uh voices are heard and this basically
is asking the legislature to go around
um that local control and I think it
sets a bad precedent and it may even um
be in violation of the conservation
easement um New Hampshire fishing game
opposed it and um I heard from Hunters
who have been up there first they say
that um the the the three predominant
weeks that they do bird hunt are the
first three weeks um in October this
would effectively take away two of those
they also use terms like um I've been up
there before for uh um while the the
trail was in use and it's like a
Speedway it's scary another person said
um I wouldn't bring my dogs up there
like these are dogs that cost thousands
of dollars so um all in all I um I think
that this is um usurping control I don't
think that it's required legislation
because dncr um has said that they would
be receptive to discussing this next
year and um and I don't think the
legislature should be um should be
working on the process thank you
representative
Ryan thank you Mr chair um as far as the
I'm I'm against this as far as the
tourism argument most of our tourists
don't come from where we live so um
people are going to come to hunt um that
and they're as far as I understand they
they probably rent rooms they um buy gas
and they eat and they probably drink
beer so they will be in our um
um in
our hotels and motels and and grocery
stores and in that area um these dogs
are very very expensive they're a very
expensive hunting tool I can't um
picture them running around trying to
hunt with Motor Vehicles going through
and the noise alone would um definitely
deter any birds that I might be hunting
I am not a hunter but I have talked to a
lot of people up there and it is it is a
very short bird hunting season so if
we're going to address it as a tourism
industry or tourism issue um we're
essentially going to shut them out and
as far as recreation resources and
development I don't believe all of our
Recreation should rely on motorized
vehicles thank
you representative
Vale thank you Mr chair um
I was listening to representative
Darby's testimony about The Five-Year
Plan and um I Echo that as well that's
one of my the reasons I am opposed to
the bill and also we have a commission
resources has a commission and we are
coming in with a new term with a lot of
people that don't have the
expertise and would need opportunity to
have access to that now now
unfortunately they don't meet again
until March um but if we were to
overlook the commission then I think we
are at serious risk of overlooking the
non-legislative solutions that
representative Darby was talking about
thank you for um recognizing me anyone
else wish to
speak saying none I'll ask the clerk to
read the
role we're voting on hb27 FN ought to
pass representative Davis
yes representative
ghoul representative Donnelly yes clerk
votes yes representative Bridle yes
representative Dupont yes representative
Looney yes representative
Taylor representative NAB yes
representative
Vil no representative Baldwin no
representative Derby no
representative Ryan no Representative
elberger
no representative
Sergeant yes and the chair
yes
133 11 to I
got I got I heard 13 to3 I heard 13 to
three if you want to I have recast your
vote you
can I have representative veale as a no
Dar representative Derby as a no and
represent elberg is a no and I'm no
Baldwin what do you have me down
for Baldwin I had as a yes no s
okay did you have 133 also I did yeah
that's what I had so okay 11 to five
okay all right that's fine
so
Ryan yep do we all agree it's 11 to five
11 to five yes okay so since we agree
I'm not going to ask him to recall it
again so 11 to five so won't go on
consent representative Derby wants to
ask for that I don't know okay and it
has a fiscal note so it'll go to finance
or one of those places um the next one
hb1 174 increasing the maximum weight of
a utility terrain vehicle to 3500 lb
unladen dry weight representative Davis
do you have a
motion thank you Mr chair I I would make
a motion not to pass thank you
representative dund second in a second
you want to speak to your motion
representative Davis yes please thank
you U I believe this this bill was put
in place to pave the way for electric
ohvs the batteries are heavier uh that
would solve some of the the complaints
right now uh pertaining to
noise uh I also believe that a lot of
the vehicles out there with the
accessories uh like a four up with four
Riders are probably overweight maybe
even some of the law enforcement
vehicles and I don't see anybody
enforcing it now if if we already have
vehicles overweight there's no nobody
out there forcing it I I don't I see it
as a moot point Thank you thank you
representative uh representative Dunn
did you want to speak to your second
I'll just say that this is Paving the
way for the electric vehicles with the
heavier batteries be less noise it be
better for everyone's complaints about
the noise thank you anyone else wish to
speak on this representative Vale I had
concerns about the use of the word
unladen and um what I've come to
understand is that that's basically the
vehicle is stripped and
so still learning about the newer bigger
vehicles I'm not thinking of electric
right now I'm more or less thinking of
um a six-seater that has air
conditioning and windows that roll
up thank you representative NAB thank
you Mr chair um I think this is a bill
we talk a lot about the 1188 commission
that's really suited for that commission
I know we have an official PLL from them
um but I think there are a lot of
unanswered questions here representative
veale indicated one the UNL dry weight
which is not def at all um you know I
think making a decision about a bill
just because you don't have enforcement
isn't a reason to do something um it's a
reason to consider how things are
enforced um I think the electric vehicle
comment is you know we don't really know
where that's going we don't know how
much usage there is um there's a lot of
times in this house a lot of distrust of
electric vehicles so having that be the
reason to pass this is um is is
something I think we need to consider
and lastly um I think there's a real
unintended consequence here you know I
know this applies to state property or
just to P public lands um but we saw
concerns from private land owners the uh
the Farm Bureau and the Timberlands
Association and you know a lot of times
when you allow these things to start
happening you lose the rights you have
so you're going to have these private
land owners who allow these vehicles um
change their mind on that and I don't
think anyone wants that direction so for
that reason I am not going to support
this Bill thank
you representative Derby thank you Mr
chair um I I don't want to repeat what
my colleagues have said I do want to let
you uh let the committee know that a
good friend of mine um has a side by
side I asked him how much his weighed it
was 1998 and he was proud that he had
been able to squeeze it under the limit
but really was looking forward to um
being able to actually put a heater in
his he brings his whole family up uh for
frequently and so I very much uh believe
that there's a there will be a need to
increase the uh the weights of um
ohvs um as my colleague uh said you know
um Timberland Owners Association Farm
Bureau as well as the National Wildlife
Federation all came out in opposition
one of the real reasons is that the Bild
does um 90% of up to 90% of the trails
are on public land private land this
doesn't uh discuss uh how to address uh
how to coordinate with those property
owners and and in particular the
easements that are already exist
existing and how people that are um
driving these uh larger Vehicles will
know um that H oh uh this section the
public section is
3500b but the next section is only 2,000
so there there are I think a number of
unanswered questions that um that the
the um 1188 study uh commission um could
help to resolve finally um I the the
jury is definitely out with respect to
um unlaid and dry weight and electric
vehicles there are definitely some um
some definitions where batteries which
are the largest weight are not included
in that weight so I don't think that
using that as a um as justification is
warranted at this point um and for those
reasons I'll be opposing it thank you
very much
thank you anyone
else seeing no one else I'll ask the
clerk to read the role voting on HB 174
ought to pass representative Davis yes
representative Gould yes representative
Donnelly yes clerk wrotes yes
representative Bridle yes representative
Dupont yes representative Looney yes
representative Taylor yes representative
NAB no no representative Veil no
representative Baldwin no representative
Derby no representative Ryan no
Representative elberger no
representative Sergeant
no 97 chair votes yes oh sorry and the
chair
s second rate citizen I don't know and
he's my friend apologies my apologies to
the chair uh 97 in favor 9 to 7 thank
you moving on executing HB 203 203
relative to ccot approved personal
flotation devices while on New Hampshire
state waters 203 I recognize uh
representative donelly for a motion
thank you Mr chair I'd like to make the
motion to
itl and representative
Dupont second so we have motion and a
second representative Donell you want to
speak to your motion thank you Mr chair
um this is I think well intentioned
there's a lot of positives that people
would like to um uh go down this
particular path but I think as a New
Hampshire resident we have uh many of
our existing laws where we have no
helmet we have no Mand Mand mandated hel
mandated uh seat Bel um and when we
start making mandates I think we start
to go down a slippery slope um and we
believe in personal resp
responsibilities um and people having
life jackets with them in their in their
their crafts at the time whether it's
you know winter or summer um they should
have uh a a life jacket this would um
change the law sometime you know mid
year and then people have to remember
what what month is it do I have to do it
this time I think this could create a
confusion and I think uh a better
education process would be better than
legislation thank you thank you
representative Dupont do you want to
speak to you a second I just said to
live by our model Live Free or
Die thank you is there anyone else that
we wishes to speak on this
bill representative Derby thank you Mr
chair just briefly um this was supported
by the department of safety this is a
safety Bill and in in particular it
helps with education I think education
of course is the key um and uh very
rarely I would expect the department of
safety to actually enforce penalties on
this but it helps them to you know um
stop people on the lake and say you know
this is the law we'll give a warning
this time and talk to them about cold
water emergence um and we saw we got a
report from the Department of Safety
that show that people die um every year
from um uh almost exclusively because
they don't have life jackets on um and
so this this likely would save um lives
so for those reasons I will be uh voting
against the it thank you thank you
anyone else representative
Vale thank you Mr
chair I will be voting against the itl
and I just just quickly want to just
probably we don't always think about
what search and rescue um comes to for
the Department of Safety for Marine
Patrol and we also know that we don't
have
an army to go help when there is an
incident on the lake it often requires
the cordination of a lot of volunteers
as well as the department of safety and
Marine Patrol and yearly we do hear
about a number of drowning deaths and
this period time period is during the
most difficult and most
challenging um weather that our state
faces and um I do believe that this
would save lives thank you anyone else
representative
Davis I'd have to say I agree with
representative Darby education is key
here uh 12 children 12 and Ender are
mandated to wear these devices and and
you are mandated to have one with you um
for the reasons that a representative
Donnelly said we are the live free and
die State and we're not mandated to wear
seat belts or motorcycle helmets I I
think this uh will align with that uh
you you still have to have it with you
you're just not mandated to have it on
you so that's I'll be voting out to
pass itl
itl that to pass the
[Laughter]
it anyone else wish to speak on this
bill I don't see any hands raised I'll
ask the clerk to read the role we're
voting on HB 203 itl motion
representative Davis yes representative
G yes representative Donnelly yes clerk
votes yes representative Bridle yes
representative Dupont yes representative
Looney yes representative Taylor yes
representative NAB no representative Vil
representative Baldwin no representative
Derby no representative Ryan
Yes Representative elberger no
representative Sergeant yes and the
chair
yes one two three four
five so it's
11 passes 11 to five 11 to five thank
you moving on HB 332 HB 332 allowing for
the establishment of a village District
to protect and remediate surface waters
representative Dupont I call on you for
a motion yes Mr chairman I move that we
itl this Bill thank you representative
Donnelly I second this so we have a
motion in a second representative D Pont
do you wish to speak to your motion yeah
I see this bill just adding a another
layer of
government uh
intrusion um House Bill 1250 failed
previously um I just don't see the need
for this thank you do you wish to speak
to your second um I would second th
those same sentiments in addition I
think it creates an exclusion type of
environment within communities um which
doesn't always Encompass the entire
community's um Mo U uh use of the the
particular lake or Pond within that
Community thank you anyone else wish to
speak on
this we'll go back to you Mr
representative
Vil thank you Mr chair I'm looking at
some testimony that was submitted
through the portal where we have the
remote
testimony and um allowing the
establishment of this Village District
would not result in a form of
water-based activities from being banned
or even regulated on a lake or Pond and
it will though give cities and towns the
ability to control pollutants such as
cyanobacteria
eoli and fos fate from entering the
lakes and ponds it will allow our
communities to develop the ability to
work together and protect the natural
resources that we have and that people
come to depend on when they come here to
Vacation um and this is from um
representative wolf sent this along to
me thank you thank you anyone else to
speak on this um you had spoken you're
the maker but we'll come back to you uh
representative sergeant
thank you Mr chairman uh as a resident
of a town with waterfront on lake sopy
and the representative of a second town
with waterfront on Lake sopy uh I know
that people in our towns are huge
supporters of this idea so that sunap uh
Newberry New London uh Springfield uh
can get together and address uh
contaminants uh going into one of our
prized Waters uh the e economic effect
of a contaminated Lake would be severe
um and that is the purpose of this is to
allow uh these towns and similar towns
around Lake babusek and other Lakes uh
to address those things and to prevent
economic harm uh to our state so I would
uh um I'm going to uh oppose the motion
to itl and would prefer a motion to pass
with an amendment that representative
Darby uh has thank you
anyone else to speak representative NB
thank you Mr chair um you know I think
it's just important to remember that
this is enabling legislation it's not
creating Village districts it's allowing
towns to create a village district for
this purpose um you know in my
experience with Town meetings the bar is
high to pass things like this so um it's
not being pushed on anyone who doesn't
have a who have a the opportunity to
oppose it we only heard one person that
was a resident of a village District
that did oppose it um they're already
place for many many other reasons so I
don't you know I I understand the
concerns about Village districts but
this doesn't create Village districts it
just enables the creation of them by
towns that are really desperately trying
to fight these issues with contaminants
in their Lakes thank
you anyone else before I go back to
representative
[Music]
dupond did you already speak
no representative Derby okay
thank you Mr chair I will be brief um
and not repeat what others have said
about the number of uh existing reasons
that um that these can be created for or
the fact that um village districts have
been um in uh law for over 100 years
I'll just point out a couple of facts
about Village districts first all the
vote voters in the towns that Village
districts are applicable to have to
approve them in each Town once the uh
district is
it's the district voters that get to um
would approve taxes so basically it
allows people to um that are affected by
the water quality to say hm we want to
improve the water quality and if they
don't want to they won't get taxed and
of course they can um uh remove
themselves they can vote to remove
themselves from the village District at
any
time um this there were some concerns
that the um waters are State regulated
um and that um uh and that there would
be some type of access uh restrictions
um but this uh the amendment that uh um
uh I sent out yesterday will uh attempts
to address those by restricting the um
uh the controls that the village
District can apply um to uh to Protec
and and remediating surface water water
quality so I um will be voting against
the uh itl I uh urge the uh committee to
U vote against it so that we can discuss
uh the amendment thank
you now representative
deont yes thank you Mr chairman I failed
to mention that we already have the
department uh New Hampshire Department
of Environmental Services that deal with
this um Also I spoke with a
representative from
snipy uh Mr Grant
and he said he stated that you already
have a water district there Village
district and I was surprised by that but
he uh that was just his opinion he said
he was all set so I don't want to put
him on the record as stating that though
but that's it thank you thank you anyone
new seeing none I'll ask the clerk to
read the role all right we voting on HB
332 itl motion representative Davis yes
representative G yes representative
Donnelly yes clerk roach yes
representative Bridle yes representative
Dupont yes representative Looney yes
representative Taylor yes representative
NAB no representative Vil no
representative Baldwin no representative
Derby no representative Ryan no
Representative elberger no
representative Sergeant no and the chair
yeah 97 bill
passes itl passes I'm sorry
itl I Bill's
zry not gonna blame you Ary but you
know okay moving on uh HB 334 FN HB 334
FN relative to the comprehensive State
development
plan believe I have a motion from
representative
D I make a motion to
itl representative Davis I'll second
representative dun do you wish to speak
to you Mo yeah I'll say a couple things
um the new language I believe is not
necessary uh the way it is currently
written is is is fine and a cost of
$500,000 to $1 million is just not
affordable in this economy it's not
something that that we can sustain it's
something that we're trying
to make a budget balanced and cut it and
it's not something we can afford at this
time thank you
representative Davis I have nothing to
say thank you anyone wish to speak on
this
bill representative
Darby thank you Mr chair only because I
didn't hear any other opposing views um
I'll just remind um the committee of uh
my briefly of my testimony that um New
Hampshire really uh is driven by its
outdoor tourism economy um and
protecting um planning for and
protecting the environment is critical
to um keeping an um an environment that
tourists want to come to also that um on
many occasions um mtbe P um the uh
Department of Environmental Services has
had to be reactionary because we
couldn't uh predict some of these
threats leading to um you know Health
impacts to our uh citizens um as well as
you know lots of costs to the state and
to the residents so um for those reasons
think that adding uh environmental um
recognition into the state development
plan um is important and I will be
opposing the ideal thank
you anyone else representative NAB thank
you Mr chair um I just think you know
things have changed probably since this
was enacted I don't know when that was
but um you know drinking water is not a
guarantee anymore and this people talk a
lot about how many straws you can put in
the ground you know I think this idea of
identifying aquifers and understanding
our Water Resources is incredible
important they're not unlimited they're
not always clean um and not having this
part of our plan I think is a real a
really shortsighted approach I also came
out of the environment and agriculture
committee with representative Davis
where we spent a lot of time talking
about landfills um and I think in you
know being sure to consider our waste as
part of our comprehensive state plan is
really important you know waste causes a
lot of problems in this state but we
have it and um and it's important to
address so I do support passing this
Bill thank you
anyone
else seeing none I'll ask the clerk to
read the role voting on HB 334
itl representative Davis yes
representative Gul representative
Donnelly yes clerk votes yes
representative Bridal yes representative
Dupont yes representative Looney yes
representative Taylor yes representative
NAB no representative Hil no
representative Baldwin no representative
Derby no representative Ryan no
Representative elberger no
representative Sergeant no and the chair
yes 97 itl
97 moving on HB 393 FN HB 393 FN
prohibiting Moorings of boats without a
permit representative Darby I see you
have a motion uh yes thank you than you
Mr chair I'd like to make a motion of
ought to pass a motion ought to pass
representative Bridal I second the
motion have have a motion made in
seconded uh do you have a subsequent
motion Mr Darby yes thank you Mr chair
I'd like to move um uh that we adopt
amendment
2025-the
in front of you and I sent this out um
last night
can you repeat the amendment number
again representative yes thank you Mr
chair
d126 h okay thank
you so everyone has that amendment in
front of them just want to make
sure you have a second on his Amendment
representative Bridal yes so we have a
motion and seconded would you like to
speak on the amendment yes thank you Mr
chair first I'll just briefly describe
the difference um in this amendment um
from the original bill um in um the the
peric paragraph 4 um originally it was
the first section of that no person
shall use spuds dot dot dot through
requiring a more artment this amendment
adds the um the last uh sentence in that
first par in that paragraph
notwithstanding any other provision of
the law and the three sub Clauses those
three sub Clauses were issues that were
um discussed and and concerns that were
raised um during testimony and um
through the help of uh some of our some
of our friends uh they were able to um
work through um those concerns and find
language that um the the stakeholders um
could agree with um and so there
therefore I'd like to propose this
amendment to uh find a bill that uh find
a version of the bill that we can all
agree
on represent Bridal do you wish to speak
to your second I would just like to
argue uh sorry agree with my colleague's
uh sentiments uh I think this really
clarifies the some of the issues that we
were having when we were listening and
hearing thank you thank you any other
discussion on the
amendment seeing none I'll ask the clerk
to read the role this is on the
amendment you're voting for the
amendment cor
right representative Davis yes
representative G yes representative
Donnelly yes clerk votes yes
representative Bridal yes representative
Dupont yes representative Looney yes
representative Taylor yes representative
NAB yes representative yes
representative Baldwin yes
representative Derby yes representative
Ryan Yes representative elberger yes
representative Sergeant yes and the
chair
yes
20 I'm sorry 160
160 for the new members we used to be to
so so the amendment passes unanimously
uh now uh representative Darby you have
another motion um yes I um thank you Mr
chair now I'd like to make a motion of
ought to pass as amended and
representative Bridal oh second that so
now we're voting on the bill as amended
the bill as amended any more discussion
on the bill as
amended seeing none let's call the
role all right voting HB 334 UT to pass
is amended representative Davis yes
representative G representative Donnelly
yes clerk votes yes representative Ral
yes representative Dupont yes
representative Looney yes representative
Taylor yes representative NAB yes
representative Vil yes representative
Baldwin yes representative Darby yes
representative Ryan Yes representative
elberger yes representative Sergeant yes
and the chair
yes
160 so I get they asked this for the
first time this year we put that on
consent everybody says yes
you have a question oh that's right it's
a fiscal note it's got to go to another
committee we'll recommend to them so
okay good thank you appreciate that uh
moving on HB 422 FN HB 422 FN increasing
penalties for violation of the Shoreland
and water quality protection
act representative Donnelly you have a
motion yes thank you Mr chair I'd like
to make a motion of an itl um
representative Bridal second so we have
a motion in a second do you wish to
speak to your motion yes thank you Mr
chair um as we heard from testimony from
Dees that this particular um violations
and penalties they have not actually
pursued any violations or penalties for
the last 10 years so they have one
currently in in that particular area um
I'm all for helping give people like the
guidance and helping them understand
this is not what you should be doing on
shorelines I actually live on a a lake
as
well by creating more of a penalty when
they don't even penalize yet let's see
how this goes let's see how because we
passed a law last year that allows them
to actually enact the penalty for 5,000
I'm wondering and we should see first
how does that affect our residents that
are building new Properties or making
modifications or adjusting any of their
Shoreline um I'm more and the mindset of
let's make sure that we're not overdoing
something when we don't even have the
numbers yet to say this is going to make
a difference um in this particular bill
so I appreciate that thank you thank you
representative bride you speak your
second uh no comments sir okay any other
comments on this
bill representative Darby thank you Mr
chair um I I believe that um I'll be
voting against the it because I believe
that um Dees uh needs um more leverage
against violators um just a personal
story uh I have a small camp on uh Lake
monomac and ringe um and uh the year
before we moved into our camp about 10
years ago uh lot was clear-cut uh lot
there was a stream ready uh next to it
the lot was clearcut uh house developed
uh lawn put in um all in violation when
the uh when the um owner was asked why
did you do this or um didn't you have to
pay a fine and he got the $10,000 uh
fine um from the town um he which means
that he had done it more than once um he
said that's the cost of doing business
so I've seen that firsthand you there
does need to be teeth um in the
penalties otherwise it's just uh it's
just an expense to them so I will be um
supporting the uh um uh voting against
the itl to support New Hampshire
Department of Environmental
Services anyone
else representative
Vale thank you Mr chair um over time we
have heard quite a bit about Shoreland
septic and about violations of the water
quality protection act but we've also
heard that Dees has had difficulty in
enforcing some of the provisions that
need to be enforced and I do believe
that I'll be voting against the itl on
the basis of a
longterm accumulation of
um facts that starts with the Shoreland
septic commission that um former
representatives from the committee
worked on so I'm just looking at this
bill and I'm thinking that we haven't
really established um
um that we don't need this bill I do
believe we do thank you anyone
else seeing none I'll ask the clerk to
read the
role voting on HB 422 itl motion
representative Davis yes representative
G representative Donnelly yes clerk
votes yes representative Bridal yes
representative Dupont yes representative
Looney yes representative Taylor yes
represent NAB no representative Vil no
representative Baldwin no representative
Derby no representative
Ryan no Representative elberger no
representative Sergeant
no 97 one more oh and the
chairs
yes
n I'll eventually get
it repr of bald going to hit him every
once in a
[Laughter]
while count n97 N9 to7 thank
you moving on next bill HB 449 HB 449
requiring requiring water
districts excuse me to provide a water
filtration system to residential
customers in certain cases
representative Baldwin I believe you
have a motion
I'd like to
move thank you representative NAB second
so we have a motion in a second
representative baldwi would you like to
speak to your
motion okay representative NAB thank you
Mr
chair so I think we heard in the
introduction of this bill that it was
trying to solve a problem and it's a
well-intentioned bill um to address an
issue with the water district
unfortunately I think that we heard also
heard during the testimony that it would
create really more problems than it was
trying to solve um it would uh it would
require the installation of water
filtration systems to residential
customers um however after the
installation it would not require the
water district to maintain those at all
so you would run into a problem of
individuals and in this case 300 indiv
individuals having to maintain them
change the filters take care of them
make sure that they were running um and
one of the things that we heard that was
very alarming is that those people who
are not maintaining it can create a
build up of contaminants and even
radioactive elements into the system
that can go back into the system so um
that is a huge problem with it and you
know it's people are well intentioned
but it's hard to take care of things
it's um uh creates more work for the
individual residents in the long term um
more significantly we also heard it
would be in violation of the federal
drinking water act so um it's really a
problematic bill that uh that doesn't
exactly work as a solution so I would
recommend it Ling it thank you thank you
anyone else
seeing none I'll ask clerk to read the
role on HB 449 voting on HB 449
itl representative Davis yes
representative G yes representative
Donnelly yes clerk votes yes
representative Bridle yes representative
Dupont yes representative Looney yes
representative Taylor yes representative
NAB yes representative Veil yes
representative Baldwin yes
representative Derby yes representative
Ryan yes representative elberger yes
representative Sergeant yes and the
chair
yes
60 so this time I can ask put this on
consent everybody says yes all right
good thank you and our last bill but
before we finish that I want to thank
everybody for an excellent uh exact
session many of you guys are freshmen I
thought uh the session is going well and
went well so I just wanted to put that
out there thank you uh h B 513 relative
to snowmobiles and Trail
connectors uh representative NAB you
have a motion I motion out to pass and
representative Sergeant a second so we
have a motion a second do you have a
second motion representative now um I
motion the adoption of amendment
85h does everyone have that should when
you front of
you
0085 just want to make sure you got it
okay representative Sergeant you're
second that
Amendment so do you wish to speak on the
amendment sure I would love to um the
underlying bill is an effort to
reestablish a disabled Trail Connection
in Sutton and I believe the amended
version of the bill um just uh makes
that clearer and more specific as to
where the um right of way would be put
in place thank you any more discussion
on the amendment representative
Darby thank you Mr chair I was wondering
if we could hear from the Department of
Transportation who testified um had some
concerns about the original bill I think
they're here um and to see what their
position is on this
amendment were the Department of
Transportation like to come to
the table
just on the question do you have a
position on the
amendment the Department of
Transportation was consulted and helped
to draft the amendment and we are
comfortable with the amendment as
prepared good thank you very much thank
you any other discussion on the
amendment so let's have a vote from the
clerk he'll call the role on the
amendment you're voting on the amendment
only repr resentative Davis yes
representative G yes representative
Donnelly yes clerk votes yes
representative Bridal yes representative
Dupont yes representative Looney yes
representative Taylor yes representative
NAB yes representative Veil yes
representative Baldwin yes
representative Derby yes representative
Ryan Yes representative elberger yes
representative Sergeant yes and the
chair yes
160 Amendment passed unanimously I will
entertain another
motion representative NAB oh thank you I
motion a to pass as amended and
representative Sergeant second so we
have a motion made and seconded ought to
pass as amended and do you wish to speak
on that motion I do not okay good
representative Sergeant no no okay so uh
I think this is going to go fairly quick
so I'm going to the amendment passed
unanimously it's now ought to pass as
amended uh clerk can you read the role
absolutely representative Davis yes
representative G representative Donell
yes clerk root yes representative rdle
yes representative Dupont yes
representative Looney yes representative
Taylor yes representative NAB
representative Vale yes representative
Baldwin yes representative Derby yes
representative Ryan Yes representative
elberger yes representative Sergeant yes
and the chair
yes 160 this is another bill that's not
FN so 160 consent consent so that's two
we put on consent I believe that covers
our 10 bills for today I'd like to thank
everybody again for an excellent first
exec session and remind you we're back
next Wednesday at 10:00 a.m. for
hearings all day so I declare the exec
session
closed thank
you all right good job I appreciate made
it you made
it I'll get it
right for